Hey youtubers it’s charlie and this week
on Arrow we met Barry Allen before he becomes
the flash, we learn all about brother blood’s
super soldier serum and malcolm merlyn runs
afoul of ra’s al ghul.
So since so much happened i’m going to do
my top 5 moments, then my review and I’ll
be doing a separate q and a video all about
the flash.
Be sure to subscribe to get it.
Remember this is just part 1 of the mid season
finale, next week is part 2.
Here we go, top 5 moments.
Number 5 - The references.
So I caught several.
see if you spotted these.
The chemical shelf in the lab and the sound
of lightning was a reference to the accident
that created the first barry allen flash in
the comic books.
The Kord Industries centrifuge is a reference
to Ted Kord, one of the many people to become
the blue beetle in the dc comics.
He was also a wealthy industrialist, Like
a nerdier version of tony stark.
The particle accelerator is going to be turned
on soon.
Probably in the next episode.
Think about how the idea of speed and the
flash work with the arrival of barry allen.
The show hasn’t physically shown us the
particle accelerator yet, but if they travel
to the site next week.
You can bet it will be part of how Barry gets
his powers.
When barry tells Oliver about how his mother
died after a person who looked like a tornado
came in murdered her, it’s a reference to
professor zoom who killed barry’s mother
in the comic books.
The Argus bunker that has the sedatives- Argus
is the SHIELD - like organization that Amanda
Waller runs and that helps out the justice
league from time to time.
Nanda Parbat - Malcolm Merlyn references the
home of the league of assassins leading moira
to contact them and let ra’s al ghul know
that malcolm is still alive.
And pretty much every sentence uttered by
Barry and Felicity when they’re together
teasing us with his destiny as the flash.
Number 4 - The stunts.
My favorite stunt was when oliver first goes
after the super soldier, he gets kicked out
the car door.
With the door.
Ouch.
Number 3 - Barry and Felicity.
So in case you missed it, the writers are
shipping Barry and Felicity hardcore.
All the most fun parts of the episode were
their scenes.
It’s hilarious that Felicity just dumps
even the thought of being with Oliver when
Barry questions their relationship.
And what about their conversation about penetration.
What if he thinks he penetrates just fine.
I feel like Felicity sexytime is just around
the corner.
Number 2 - Felicity brings Barry to the Arrow
Cave.
So barry is now completely in on Oliver’s
whole operation.
He just figures it all out with that look
around.
The weapons, the tech, and Oliver lying comatose
on the table.
Barry is now officially on team arrow.
Think of it as like a justice league teaser.
Two members down, one cowl, some oreo’s,
a golden lasso and a red cape and you’re
good to go.
and my number 1 moment - Meeting Barry Allen.
Heir to the speedforce and the only person
on earth faster than superman.
unless you count professor zoom.
The introduction of barry was so much fun.
He’s not the flash yet.
That’s supposed to happen next week.
But everything about his first on screen appearance.
The ‘train imagery’, the pouring droplets
of rain.
And so so many jokes teasing us.
But let me know what your favorite moment
was and if you saw any references that I didn’t
mention.
Overall I give the episode an A+ for just
being so much fun and being so bold with all
the dc universe references.
And doing it in a way that felt authentic
to the world arrow has created.
The writers said that this was all about the
flash being part of oliver story, not oliver
being part of the flash’s story.
The soundtrack was really appropriate too.
Especially that first scene with Barry and
Felicity alone together.
It almost sounded like christmas music, like
arrow is giving us a red blurry present.
Don’t open it too fast.
Let me know what you thought of the episode.
Like I said, next week he will get his powers.
Be sure to subscribe to get my video for that.
I’m also doing a new show called Ask Emergency,
it’s just a video I’ll start doing once
or twice a week where i take your questions
about a specific topic and answer them.
This week it will be all about Grant Gustin
and the future of the flash.
Including what’s happening with him on arrow
and the spinoff show.
So write your questions for that in the comments
and click here to get my answers.
I’ll add the annotation when I post the
video in the morning.
And click here to get my last arrow video.
Thanks so much for watching, see you guys
tomorrow, super fast high fives!
(yuuuuuh noise).